GETTING THE SUPPLIES IN, THAT
COULD BE CONSEQUENTIAL.
FRED PLEITGEN IN BELGOROD,
RUSSIA, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> THIS MORNING, I HAD A CHANCE
TO SPEAK WITH TATA MARAHAN, SHE
MOVED FROM DONBAS REGION IN THE
EAST TO THE CAPITAL KYIV IN 2015
TO STUDY INTERNATIONAL LAW.
BUT NOW SHE IS SERVING WITH A
VOLUNTEER MEDICAL BATTALION THAT
HAS BEEN RESPONDING TO THE LOSS
OF LIFE, INJURIES ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THIS CONFLICT.
I STARTED BY ASKING HER WHAT
SHE'S SEEING RIGHT NOW ON THE
STREETS OF THE CAPITAL.
>> WHAT AM I SEEING?
I'M SEEING DEAD CHILDREN.
I'M SEEING HOSPITALS BEING
BOMBED.
I'M SEEING CHURCHES BEING
IT IS DIFFICULT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TELL YOU.
WHAT AM I SEEING?
I'M SEEING MY PEOPLE DIE.
I'M SEEING ALL SORTS OF HORRIBLE
THINGS.
I STUDIED CRIMES AGAINST
HUMANITY AT THE UNIVERSITY.
I STUDIED INTERNATIONAL
HUMANITARIAN LAW.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SEE THIS
WITH MY OWN EYES IN MY COUNTRY.
SO, YEAH, THIS IS WHAT I'M
SEEING.
>> IT IS HORRIBLE.
IT IS HORRIBLE TO IMAGINE.
WE HAVE SEEN THE IMAGES TOO.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE?
>> OH, YEAH.
I DO FEEL SO.
I'VE NEVER BEEN MORE HAPPY TO BE
UKRAINIAN.
I'VE NEVER BEEN MORE LUCKY TO BE
BORN IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE ALL ARE CONSOLIDATING AND ONE
PERSON MAYBE IS POWERLESS TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE, BUT TRUST ME,
WE'RE NOT ONE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
FIGHTING HERE, BACK TO BACK.
SO, YEAH, WE DO HAVE HOPE.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU, WE HAVE
SEEN AND I'VE BEEN TOLD BY MY
OWN SOURCES IN THE U.S. THAT
RUSSIA IS NOT JUST ACCIDENTALLY
HITTING CIVILIANS, BUT PERHAPS
INTENTIONALLY.
AND I WONDER IF YOU SEE THAT
BASED ON THE PEOPLE YOU'RE
TREATING.
>> IT IS NOT ACCIDENTAL
WHATSOEVER.
THIS IS JUST SO RIDICULOUS.
MY PARENTS, MY FAMILY, THIS WAS
A CITY THAT -- THIS IS A CITY
THAT IS ON THE VERGE OF
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
AND IT HAS BOMBED THE HELL OUT
OF IT.
I CAN'T RECOGNIZE THE STREETS ON
PICTURES.
AND THE GOVERNMENT SORT OF
NEGOTIATED FOR GREEN CORRIDOR,
TO EVACUATE CIVILIANS, THEY SORT
OF MADE SURE THAT THE EVACUATION
TRANSPORT CAN COME NEAR TO THE
BORDER AND EVACUATE PEOPLE.
AND ONCE THEY WERE ON THEIR WAY
TO THE CITY, THE RUSSIAN FORCES
BEGAN ATTACKING THEM.
THE CIVILIANS.
THE EVACUATION BUSES.
THERE IS NO WAY THIS WAS BY
ACCIDENT.
THIS WAS JUST -- THIS MAKES ME
LAUGH.
I'M SORRY.
>> I KNOW SO MUCH OF THIS IS
ABOUT YOUR HOMETOWN AND YOUR
FAMILY.
TELL US HOW THAT IS DRIVING YOU
NOW.
>> WITH MY HOMETOWN, I KNOW -- I
KNOW IT IS DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE
TO SORT OF REALIZE THAT THE
SCALE OF THE SITUATION RIGHT
NOW, BUT JUST IMAGINE THAT THERE
IS A CITY AND THERE IS A TOWN,
SMALL TOWN, AND YOU'VE SPENT
THERE 17 YEARS OF YOUR LIFE, YOU
DROVE YOUR BIKE OVER THERE AND
YOU WENT TO SCHOOL, YOU SPOKE TO
YOUR NEIGHBORS, YOU LIVED AND
LOVED, YOU LAUGHED THERE, AND
THE OTHER DAY YOU SEE THE TOWN,
IT IS COMPLETELY BOMBED, AND
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE HOUSE,
THERE IS NOW -- I DON'T KNOW THE
RIGHT TERM, I'M SORRY.
THE LAST THING I WANT IS FOR MY
BEAUTIFUL KYIV